hello everyone and welcome to the April
2020 me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carol strange days of
course where we're all worried about the
spread of the corona virus covered 19
pandemic across the world under lockdown
or some version of quarantine or
something like that as I said before
Jennifer my wife and I are much better
equipped to deal with something like
this than many people our jobs involve
working from home we have a nice home we
have relatively stable and predictable
income and so forth so we're doing okay
we like being at home also compared to
you know any the most people although it
would be really nice to be able to go
outside see friends things like that but
anyway I do hope everyone out there in
listening land podcast land patreon
supporter land is doing well under these
circumstances I know it's not easy I
know there's lots of resources out there
for people look at try to deal with the
effects of the lockdown and the pandemic
whether it's the medical effects are
also the psychological effects you know
the psychological effects are very real
and should be you should go to great
lengths and take care of yourself in
situations like this I mean someone like
me for example has a lot of time to do
work I do in fact spend a lot of time
now doing quote-unquote work but that's
not making me very productive to be
honest it's just too easy to get
distracted worrying about the state of
the world and so forth and in some sense
that's okay that's just something to be
expected but you have to manage it you
have to figure out ways to get through
one way to get through is to listen to
good podcasts and ask questions and
answer them so let's do that let's go
[Music]
first question this month is from valkia
who says in your February AMA you said
the Big Bang wasn't created by anything
in the conventional story I and others
have some other stories but that's the
mystery what is your preferred story for
how the Big Bang was created so the
answer is I don't have a preferred story
I do think that there are many different
models on the market that are plausibly
somewhat on the right track that is to
say they will capture something
important about what's really happening
or what really did happen at the Big
Bang it's also completely plausible to
me that none of the current models on
the market capture anything important
about what happened at the Big Bang what
we know about the Big Bang is there was
a period of very very high temperature
high density high curvature of
space-time about 14 billion years ago
that led directly to a hot dense smooth
expanding universe that cooled into the
universe we see today that's what we
know but our theories whether it's
general relativity or quantum field
theory or whatever are just not up to
the task of saying what happened at that
moment so it's okay under those
circumstances that we have lots of
different theories we don't know which
one is true I would say it's even
premature to say to have it had a
favorite right you might have a favorite
way of approaching the problem but to
say you have a favorite theory I think
is wildly premature at this time John
Hamel says dan dennett told you that the
little-people argument against freewill
scepticism is obnoxious but then he went
on to rely on precisely that argument
himself just a few moments later his
thought experiment assumed that an
average person who who was told that
they have no free will would become
slovenly and make bad decisions so that
pretty soon they ended up in court
are you surprised then that a freewill
skeptic like Jerry Coyne has somehow
avoided prison or is it just that the
little people without a PhD who would
immediately begin a crime spree upon
being told they have no free will so I
think that this misunderstands the
argument that Dan was making at least as
I understand it I'm I shouldn't try to
speak for him but I will under these
circumstances nothing in Dan's argument
has anything to do with little pea
bull or people with PhDs the argument is
about how you behave given that you do
or do not accept the idea that you have
free will if you look closely Dan never
made any distinctions between people who
are sophisticated knowers of philosophy
and science versus just people on the
street what he said was there's a
distinction between people who accept
the existence of free will and people
who don't
namely that if you don't accept the
existence of free will you can't accept
the existence of things like moral
responsibility for your actions because
you have no responsibility for your
actions if you I think that his argument
is that people who deny the existence of
free will are simply not being
consistent unless they act in that
really a social way that the cartoonish
way you say well I can't be held
responsible I can just you know become
sociopathic etc no one does that but I
think Dan's point is that that would be
the intellectually consistent position
if you truly did not believe in free
will the truth is of the people who deny
the existence of free will are
constantly telling other people how to
behave making decisions about how to
behave for themselves etc and this
reality of the situation is exactly what
is taken seriously by compatible lists
compatible lists want to understand how
we should conceptualize the fact that
real people talk about making decisions
and assign moral import to those
decisions all the time and compatible to
say that's okay that we shouldn't deny
that we need that kind of language that
kind of apparatus to get through life so
let's try to understand it the best way
we can Philip my 'men says you have a
very unique and engaging even contagious
style of speaking for example with
subtle inflections at the end of
sentences that subtextual 'i ask the
listener if they're still with you this
makes me very self-conscious when I'm
reading this out loud Philip but I will
I will soldier on
I find myself unconsciously slipping
into your Cadence's when teaching did
you develop this style intentionally or
did it just evolve or have you always
spoken this way I certainly didn't
develop any style intentionally this is
just how I talk of course it has evolved
over over time but certainly not in any
con
why I'm not against that you know I did
certainly work very hard at public
speaking and things like that I don't
think there's any authenticity argument
that says that you shouldn't try to
affect how you look how you stand how
you talk or anything like that but in
the case of my actual Cadence's and
rhythms of speaking
I have exerted no control over them
whatsoever this is just how they came
out I personally really don't like
listening to myself this is one of the
reasons why the podcast is only very
minimally edited I'm doing I'm the one
doing the editing and I'm not going to
listen to the whole episode but and I
know that empirically other people out
there some of them like the way I speak
and some don't and that's perfectly okay
that's that's just how it's gonna be
this is how I'm gonna talk there are
definitely people out there who have
very distinctive ways of talking whether
it's you know people like Lenny Susskind
or David Albert we've had on the podcast
here and it's always interesting it's
you know just part of the wonderful
variety of life that people talk in
different ways
Toni B says does the universe getting
clumpy err with time effect cosmology in
the expansion of the universe the early
universe would have would have been
uniform with the same mass and dark
energy everywhere but now there are huge
voids with basically just dark energy
could this exaggerate the acceleration
of expansion so this is actually a or at
least it was in the last couple decades
a very hot topic in theoretical
cosmology does the difference between a
perfectly homogeneous universe where we
can solve all the equations exactly for
how the expansion proceeds versus the
lumpy in homogeneous universe in which
we live does that difference really
spell a huge difference for how the
overall universe expands there were a
group of people who claimed that there
was a way of analyzing it which said
that the inhomogeneities in the universe
did in fact mimic cosmic acceleration
however I personally was always
extremely doubtful about that I think
that the sort of mathematical techniques
that they used were unconvincing to me
and I believe although maybe you should
check for yourself but I believe the
current consensus is it just does does
not work that way
I mean one way of thinking about this is
to think of an effective field theory of
large-scale structure that is something
that I've written the paper about and
there you see that the overall expansion
rate is more or less unaffected by
inhomogeneities so here's one way of
thinking about it
the in some large region of space the
total amount of mass and energy is the
same whether it's homogeneous ly or in
homogeneous ly distributed what's
different is that there's a
gravitational field right in
homogeneities change the gravitational
field in an interesting way but how in
the world could the effect of that extra
gravitational field be more important to
the overall expansion of space than the
effect of the mass that is actually
sourcing most of the energy or the dark
energy or whatever you would expect
intuitively the gravitational field that
just be a tiny tiny very weak
perturbation on top of that and I
believe that is what the mathematics
bears out igorevich says what is your
take on nuclear power plants as a source
of energy would you enforce or
discourage their use how do you see its
safety and efficiency compared to safety
efficiency of the alternatives I'm not
an expert on the current state of the
art in terms of the safety or efficiency
of nuclear power intuitively and since I
was very young I thought that nuclear
power was a perfectly sensible way to
move forward I don't have any big big
fundamental philosophical objections to
it I don't think it's the best way
long-term to do power here on earth I
think that ultimately we want a
completely renewable energy source
pipeline as much as we can whether it's
solar or geothermal or whatever
now cosmically speaking nothing is
completely renewable the earth will
cease to exist in five billion years or
whatever but still billions of years as
the timescale works for me and nuclear
power is not a renewable resource in
quite that way there are absolutely
issues with the storage of nuclear waste
and so forth I talked a little bit with
Martin Rees about that on the podcast
but I think I agree with his take that
in the medium term as a bridge to long
term truly renewable power nuclear power
seems to make sense
on the other hand my credence azar not
that set in stone
if someone really understands the
dangers and convinces me otherwise I
will change my mind
Charles Hertz says I'm baffled by
something I read in Brian Greene's
newest book until the end of time on
page 360 says light emitted from a
distant location is visible to our
telescopes only if there has been ample
time for it to have traversed the space
between us we can calculate that it's
about 45 billion light years
so assuming space is infinite you can
picture it as a patchwork of widely
separated 90 billion light year regions
I just don't get it if there's a guy in
a galaxy 10 billion light-years north of
me can can't he theoretically see ten
billion light years farther in that
direction than I can ten billion light
years less far in the opposite direction
how can there be separate independent
regions since his region mine are
different but overlap substantially so I
think you're both right but yours too
emphasizing slightly different things
what Brian says is you can picture it as
a patchwork of widely separated regions
more or less evolving independently but
you are also correct at that division
into patchwork is by no means set in
stone you know different ways of
dividing it up will give you different
answers it's not as if they're literally
our boundaries around us 45 billion
light years in every direction and in
fact Brian is cheating a little bit
because it's not true a hundred percent
that they're that these things will
evolve completely independently there
will be very very small effects of
what's going on on different sides of
the different parts of the universe so I
I don't I would just say don't take him
too literally okay it's a it's a pretty
good approximation to think of these
different regions of the universe
however you want to divide them up as
evolving more or less independently the
new Mazzara says in many worlds every
time the universe splits we become two
different people why can't we say that
each of us becomes one of these
descendants for example I turn out to be
the one who observes the spin-up
electron well my other self is the one
who observes the spend-down
isn't this necessary in order to
preserve our sense of identity so the
answer is just that there's absolutely
no distinction between the version of
you who observes Ben
than the versions observed spin-down
except that one observes been up one of
their spin down there's absolutely
nothing in there that says and this one
is the real you
that's what would be necessary to make
sense of this idea that there is some
essence of eunice that travels down one
set of branches and not any other one so
in terms of preserving your sense of
identity no I don't think that anything
like that would be necessary the notion
of personal identity is different in
many worlds than it is in a single world
theory but that doesn't mean it's
incoherent you can go backwards uniquely
to know where you were in the past when
you go forwards you don't know who
you're going to be in fact we can say
equivalently the other way you know that
your present self will evolve into many
different future selves period that's it
you cannot also say and I don't know
which one I'm gonna be what you can say
is I will evolve into these many
different selves and I think as I tried
to argue in something deeply hidden that
if you really really dig into what you
mean by personal identity anyway where
you understand that for example you
right now is not exactly the same as you
one day ago all of this fits in together
perfectly well it's just a little bit
different than what we're used to Martin
Dusek says how does the many-worlds
hypothesis affect the simulation
hypothesis wouldn't a hilbert space of
worlds reduce the probability of living
inside a simulation I don't think so I
mean if you believe the simulation
argument at all then you have to believe
in the possibility of super
technologically advanced civilizations
outside our reality and who knows what
their reality is I mean who all we can
do is sort of give them almost arbitrary
power to do simulations other than that
we know nothing about them so whether or
not they choose to simulate a classical
universe or a quantum universe I don't
really see it makes any difference at
all like they have the power to do any
of that I mean we we don't necessarily
imagine that they're building their
version of a supercomputer right I mean
maybe we are being simulated on their
version of an abacus they're really
really powerful we just have no way of
judging
Anders says does the cosmos feel
constant affect the flow of time if we
could build a vacuum energy suction
device and extract the vacuum energy
from a volume of space and then send one
of the two clocks into that volume wait
for a long time and then take the clock
out again would we see a difference
between the two clocks so I'm not going
to quite answer this question Anders
because we cannot build a vacuum energy
suction device this is not a thing we
can build the whole point of vacuum
energy is that as long as it truly is
vacuum energy it's exactly the same
amount everywhere you can't move it
around now you can imagine a phase
transition you can imagine phase
transition where the vacuum energy
changes inside a bubble so that it's a
different interior to the bubble than
exterior to the bubble and you could
send a clock into the bubble and then
pull it out maybe that's sort of what
you're talking about
there would be a gravitational effect of
that absolutely and it's no different
than the gravitational effect of taking
your clock and putting it in a spherical
shell of really dense material right if
you had a spherical shell that was
hollow inside and SuperDuper dense so it
had a gravitational field then the clock
that just stayed inside the shell would
have a different total amount of time
elapsed than one that started inside the
shell went out hung around outside for a
while and then came back in likewise
there's a there's a certain amount of
gravity associated with a bubble of a
false vacuum energy then the same thing
would happen with that clock it doesn't
necessarily have to happen because it
depends on details but that's absolutely
possible but I don't think any of that
is actually addressing what you're
probably really getting at because you
said does the cosmological constant
affect the flow of time the point is any
any form of energy which is completely
homogeneous right which is the same
everywhere can be solved in Einstein's
equations for general relativity by a
metric by a space-time curvature where
time is unaffected okay where everyone
has the same notion of proper time
everyone has a notion of what the
clocks read to them if they are
stationary with respect to the rest
frame of this energy so clock still take
it one second per second whether or not
there's a cosmological constant in our
universe
Charlie McLaughlin says what kinds of
experiments could be constructed and
implemented to prove many worlds so
there are none because there are no
experiments constructed implement to
prove any scientific theory this of
course requires a footnote because
scientists and mathematicians use the
word proof in a slightly different way
than other people do you know like the
people on the street if you said well
prove that you purchased this from our
store they would show you a receipt and
go here's my proof okay but scientists
and mathematicians logicians
philosophers have a higher standard they
really want the word proof to be like a
mathematical or logical demonstration
something with literally no possible
loopholes a receipt can be faked right
scientist would say their receipt is
evidence for the fact that you bought
something at that store but it's not a
proof so if we change your question just
to say what kind of experiments could be
constructed implement to provide
evidence for many worlds there are
millions and they've been done the whole
idea of many worlds is that there is
nothing but a wave function and that
wave function obeys the Schrodinger
equation so every experiment that says
there's a wave function and the wave
function obeys the Schrodinger equation
is evidence for many worlds what you
really probably want is to know is can
there be evidence against many worlds
given the quantum mechanics basically is
okay and the answer to that is also yes
just do an experiment where the
wavefunction does not obey the
Schrodinger equation this is an
absolutely possible thing Roger Penrose
thinks that the wave function does not
obey the Schrodinger equation when it
describes pieces of the universe where
the gravitational field is different in
them he thinks that that causes an
objective sudden collapse of the
wavefunction and experiments are ongoing
to look for exactly that which would
falsify the many worlds theory Justin
Bailey says how do black holes have spin
in charge when they're really a region
of space rather than an object with
solid properties well because regions of
space can have spin and charge
this is a feature of general relativity
you know remember once you go not only
to general relativity but to modern
physics more generally fields are the
things that the universe is made of the
universe is not made of particles so if
you see an electron with an electric
charge and spin you have no problem with
that remember that the electron is
really a quantized excitation of the
electron field so fields even though
they're spread out through space can be
associated with spin and with charge
namely with angular momentum and with a
coupling to the electromagnetic field so
there's no surprise at all really that
black holes are the same way black holes
are a feature of the gravitational field
the space-time metric that tells us the
curvature of space-time and there's it
just makes perfect mathematical sense to
associate a region of space-time with a
total amount of both charge and spin as
well as mass for that reason for that
for that matter
dillan padilha says i've been reading
what is real by adam becker former
mindscape test and i find it crazy how
generations of physicists before you
viewed and treated some of those who
were interested in the foundations of
quantum mechanics do you see your
generation as more accepting of a more
bottom-up approach to doing physics you
know I'm always very skeptical of
generalizing when it comes to general
generations I think that there were
always people who are interested in the
foundations of quantum mechanics I do
think that there are still such people
today I it's plausible to me that the
tide is changing and amongst the
majority of physicists they're becoming
a little bit more open to investigations
in quantum foundations and this is very
very vague and hedgy for intentional
reasons cuz I don't know how to quantify
this I mean I've never done a survey
that is scientific in any way but given
the advances of technology with what
quantum mechanics can do quantum
computers but also manipulations of
quantum matter and so forth digging into
the quantum into the foundations of
quantum mechanics just seems like a more
sensible thing to do than it ever did
before so people are becoming a little
bit more open to it I don't want to give
my generation special credit or anything
like that but I do like to think that
things might be changing
dan inch says do you have any plans to
do another podcast on quantum mechanics
with David Albert your conversation and
March 2019 is one of my favorites but by
the end he both sounded as though you
needed time to reflect we actually need
time to do was just to go because David
had an appointment he had to go to we
ended up talking a long time but you
know as of right now I do not have any
plans to repeat any guests on mindscape
you know David's one of my favorite
people and best thinkers that I know so
he'd be a great person have one again
but I know lots of people who'd be great
to have on again talking about similar
things you know I've been intentionally
staying away from quantum mechanics for
the last few months because we overdosed
on that a little bit but quantum
mechanics will eventually return but
there's a lot of people to talk to and I
don't want to sort of just be retreads
of similar conversations over and over
again having said that if we do start
having repeats David Lee one of the best
people to have wes clyborn says I'm
curious about the current state of
m-theory and the best current
explanations for the weakness of gravity
so those are two slightly different
questions wes is trying to sneak in
there I'll give short answers to both of
them I'm not really sure how to
characterize the current state of
m-theory you know I mean m-theory is not
even a well-defined thing it's sometimes
used as a superset of string theory
right like string theory evolved into M
theory sometimes M theories used as a
subset of string theory that there's a
particular limit of string theory where
things look like 11 dimensional super
gravity and that's the m-theory limit
probably more often it's used in the
former sense that M theory is the theory
whose limits include 11 dimensional
string theory as well as various
different super string theory 11
dimensional super gravity plus various
different string theories but the state
of it is you know I have been following
it to be honest I used to follow it
better but in the last ten years they've
been at Caltech I haven't followed along
very well and also I think that the
people who are technically string
theorists their interests have changed
no I've had I guess three legitimate
card-carrying string theorists on the
podcast we had Leonard Susskind we had
Clifford Johnson we had Brian Greene
none of them quite wants to say
I am a string theorist alright they want
to say well I'm a theoretical physicist
I'm a quantum field theory stand and
theorist or whatever which tells you
something okay and many of these people
right now are doing things that are
inspired by discoveries in M theory or
string theory but they're not actually
technically M theory or string theory
they're calculations done in gravity
quantum gravity tensor networks
a DSC of T etc so I worry that a lot of
people working in that field as a whole
have lost touch with the goal to
eventually contact with data and explain
the universe that we see I never worried
that it was hard to make contact with
data like that's okay that's fine is
that sometimes things are just hard that
doesn't make them not worth doing but I
do worry if you just don't even try and
that's what I worry is happening
okay current explanations for the
weakness of gravity there is something
called the weak gravity conjecture which
is probably what you're referring to
again I don't have anything deep to say
about it it's not a proven thing it's
the kind of thing that if you make
certain assumptions then you can prove
it and the conjecture states that
roughly speaking among two objects that
are charged under some non gravitational
force gravity will always be weaker than
that non gravitational force so it's
more sophisticated NAPA that's the basic
idea so you know that's a good thing to
investigate maybe it tells us something
deep but I'm not really an expert Dave
Stern says on page 172 is something
deeply hidden you have the example of a
bowling ball that becomes two bowling
balls when the wavefunction branches the
energy contribution of the two child
bowling balls equals the energy
contribution of the parent bowling ball
could this lead to observations that
would be evidence for the many-worlds
hypothesis so I don't think so
to be honest you know I've already given
my feelings about experiment in many
worlds nearly you can try to falsify it
but you can't try to prove it okay we
already have overwhelming evidence for
the two main claims that many-worlds
says are true the thing we should be
looking for or is evidence for claims
that it's not true and people are doing
that now when it comes to the two
bowling balls with different energies I
do think there's an interesting thing to
be said about quantum mechanic
I'm currently trying to finish up a
paper where I say that here's an
experimental situation where you can
observe energy not being conserved in
quantum mechanics my student at Caltech
jackie loud Minh and I are writing a
paper pointing that out it's something
that has sort of been vaguely gestured
toward in other papers before but more
with you know sort of reluctance then
enthusiasm and we're saying look here's
an experiment you can actually do to see
energy not being conserved on our branch
of the wavefunction so maybe that's
something that will be feasible or our
proposed experiment is not quite
feasible but maybe it'll lead some
better experimenters to propose
something that is feasible
George winters says my question is about
conservation of energy and other basic
principles in relation to many worlds
if such principles apply am I correct to
understand that all these divergent
trajectories have to happen in already
existing universes otherwise there will
be constantly occurring cases of sudden
energy momentum mass etc so no I don't
think that's quite the way to think
about it the energy in the global wave
function of the universe is just
conserved in many worlds full-stop
perfectly obvious mathematical
conclusion from the formalism many world
says there's a wave function it obeys
the Schrodinger equation there's a
formula for the energy there's a formula
for the evolution and the energy is
constant done but the dividing of that
wavefunction into many semi-classical
branches might have the feature that
observers don't see energy being
conserved as I just said so but having
said that the way that we divide up the
branches into the wave function into
many branches has a certain subjective
character so you don't need to but you
can imagine that all of the branching
already happened in other words there
never was one branch that divided into
many there were always many branches but
just all of those branches looked
exactly the same and then they became
different looking as time goes on I
don't like that way of talking about it
it doesn't help me it doesn't really
solve any problems but for some people
it seems to
be you know very reassuring to know that
they can think of it that way and in
that case go ahead and think of it that
way Judith Marsh says if physicists and
educators taught that the earth was in
motion in the classroom but
ontologically didn't accept it nobody
would believe that the earth really
moves if we weren't socialized to
suspend our common-sense disbelief about
a moving earth we wouldn't believe that
it does it's been over a hundred years
since minkowski's space and time lecture
why hasn't humanity made the ontological
paradigm shift to static time like it
did for a dynamic earth I don't know you
know I mean I think a lot of it is just
that the arguments that well so there's
a couple things here number one I have
no idea what is meant by the phrase
static time it's used again in another
question it's a couple questions from
now static time seems to be a
contradiction in terms
to me static means not changing with
time and time is time so I don't even
know what it would mean for time to be
static or non static it's just a sort of
a non sequitur in my mind but if what
you mean is why haven't we internalized
the four dimensional space-time picture
of reality rather than the absolute
space three-dimensional space plus
absolute one-dimensional time picture
you know it's just very far from our
experience number one and number two
there's no need for most people to
understand the arguments that go into
that right it's much easier to
understand the arguments that the earth
is moving then they understand the
arguments for special relativity and the
absent and the the non-existence of an
absolute notion of simultaneity so you
know people like me try to get people to
understand it and we you know there's
lots of people out there who think it's
interesting and do understand it but the
fact that most people in the street
haven't internalized it I don't think
it's very surprising or really the worst
thing that is going on in the world
right now so you know I think that
there's different you know I love
knowledge I love understanding the world
I want to share it with everybody but I
don't get mad at people who don't share
my love of knowledge that way I get mad
at people who do dumb things who do bad
things but if people just want to go
through their lives with a certain
comfortable picture of the world that
doesn't cause harm to anybody else
it's a choice that they should be able
to make and that's perfectly okay with
me I just wanted to be an educated
choice I want them to know that that's
the choice they're making quite sure if
that's a contradiction or not but maybe
I should think about that a little bit
harder
Tony ICI offer Dhoni says I would like
to know when the double-slit experiment
was first performed and how it was
carried out so Tony you're much more
likely to get that by googling or by
looking at Wikipedia by asking me I
really don't know what the experimental
situation was I know that people talked
about the double slit experiment long
before they actually did it and by the
double slit I mean the quantum version
of the double slit of course Thomas
young did a classical double slit
experiment long before quantum mechanics
was invented but that's not exactly what
we're talking about here David lang says
Carlo Rovelli
in his book the order of time talks
about the distance light has to travel
to an event as the extended present that
lays between past and future can you
explain this idea any further I'm not
sure if I can you know I've not read
that book I mean I know what the truth
is which is that you know if you imagine
ourselves at an event at a moment in
time and a location in space okay then
from that one single event you can
distinguish three different regions of
space-time the future the future is all
the points you can get to all the
moments of time and locations in space
that you can get to moving more slowly
than the speed of light the past which
is the set of all points in space and
time that can get to you along paths
that move more slowly than the speed of
light and elsewhere else when right
someplace that is not either in your
past or your future and probably that's
what Carlo talks about as the extended
present the point being that to a
Newtonian who believed in absolute space
and time the idea of the present moment
extends uniquely from here at this one
moment of space-time all across the
universe whereas in special relativity
or general relativity for that matter
the notion of the present time might
look different to different observers
depending on what coordinates they use
and what motion they have in the
universe etcetera
and therefore all we can do is take the
collection of all the events in
space-time that are effectively neither
in our present in our in our future nor
our past and you can call that the
extended present if you like this is
very hard to explain without drawing
things which is a limitation of an
audio-based
medium Sigurd ankov says is it possible
to determine lower bounds on the
computational space complexity memory of
computational of computable mathematical
models that may underpin a static time
universe again I have no idea what
static time means in this context sorry
about that and then the question
continues post slightly differently if a
computable mathematical model forms the
basis of a static time universe is it
feasible that such model may be
stateless in a sense analogous to the
property of a Mandelbrot set which has
complex structure and apparent emergent
entropy although any point in the
parameter space can be evaluated
independently
I really don't quite understand what is
being asked here I think you're using a
lot of words that are either being used
in slightly technical or slightly
non-standard ways that I don't quite
understand so sorry about that I'm just
not the person to ask this question to
kirk Briggs says my question is about
permission section 107 of the u.s.
copyrights website contains the list of
purposes for which the reproduction of a
particular work may be considered fair
use this includes quoted material for
use in teaching do you obtain permission
to quote another author in your books
and how would I go about obtaining your
permission to quote you it depends so
this is one of the reasons why I'm a
scientist and not a lawyer is because a
lot of guidelines legally are very vague
and they're sort of intentionally so so
that judges and the judicial system more
broadly can figure out what the best
ways to interpret those over time
actually are there is an idea of fair
use where you can take a little tiny bit
of someone else's work and quote it or
reproduce it in your own work and
there's an idea of parody where you're
allowed to do that but how much you can
quote changes from context to context so
poetry for example is very difficult to
get from
do you basically need permission to even
quote one line from a poem if you're
really being legal about it whereas just
a text from a book you can quote several
sentences that's no problem if I have an
extended quote from somebody than just
out of politeness I will ask them so I
did I had an extended quote from Andrew
Ian Carl Sagan's wife in the big picture
and we got permission from her to do it
I don't think we needed permission
it was perfectly covered under fair use
so if you're just quoting a few
sentences or even a short paragraph from
anything that I've written then go ahead
and do it by all means if you want more
than that then probably talking to my
publisher
Dutton books is the way to go Santiago
Torres says can you share any thoughts
on ideas you have for your next trade
book so my preference is not to do that
I have lots of ideas for the next trade
book but until you know a substantial
part of the book is actually written
which makes me think this is definitely
going to happen I'm always reluctant to
do that far ahead of time I will make an
exception not quite for the next trade
book but it is becoming real my hope to
actually write a text book on quantum
mechanics I've signed a contract to do
that now so I have to get off my butt
and actually start writing that I've
written a little bit of it but much most
the vast majority of it has yet to be
written so there will be an
undergraduate textbook in quantum
mechanics for physics majors so people
who know a little bit of calculus and
linear algebra and so forth but that is
definitely going to be written or
released I put myself under an
obligation to write that over the next
couple years Demetriou Shevchenko says
how exactly is the wave function is the
wave nature of quantum fields related to
the world word wave in wave function are
they the same types of waves or perhaps
one is emergent from the other neither
one they're not the same type of waves
and one is not a version from the other
the quantum fields are quantized
versions of classical fields so fields
are wavy already to start okay that's
what a field is a field is something
that has a definite value at every
single location in space and time so if
it's oscillating up and down that's what
you call a wave the difference between a
wave function
classical wave like that is that the
classical waves
there's several differences one is just
that every different kind of field has
its own feel okay there's an electric
field a magnetic field the electron
field the gravitational field these are
all completely separate from each other
in principle whereas the wave function
is a feature of the whole universe all
at once the wave function quantum
mechanics it's just a bad name because
when they started inventing quantum
mechanics and they were thinking about
one particle just had a position then
the wave function of a single particle
looks a lot like a classical wave right
it's just a number a complex number but
still just a number at every point in
space but once you go beyond one
particle once you go to like two
particles you don't have two different
waves for the two particles you have a
single wave function that assigns a
complex number to every possible pair of
places they could be every possible
values for where one particle could be
and where another particle could be and
for the universe as a whole you assign a
complex number to every configuration of
the stuff in the universe so it's a very
different kind of thing than a classical
wave or even a quantum field wave which
just comes from starting with that
classical wave and quantizing it it's
just the word wave is used because
they're functions that's nothing more
deep than that Frank Cochran says
understanding that you have concerns
with eternal inflation theory given your
statement that you assigned a 50%
probability to its validity do you
believe that a non metaphysics argument
can one day be made for its existence so
I'm not sure what the phrase non
metaphysics is doing there I don't think
there are any metaphysics arguments for
or against a specific physical theory
like eternal inflation so I'm gonna
stick to physics arguments if that's
okay and again I think that there's
absolutely physics arguments that can be
used to provide evidence you know you
don't prove scientific theories you
provide evidence for them so inflation
makes predictions whether it's eternal
inflation or not the kinds of
predictions it makes are kind of
probabilistic inflation is not a certain
specific absolutely ironclad theory it's
a paradigm into which many
theories can fit so it's very often the
case that any particular kind of
prediction that inflation might want to
make such as the existence of
gravitational waves generated by the
inflationary period in the early
universe if you try hard enough you can
wriggle out of that prediction while
inflation is still actually true to me
that's not a problem with inflation
that's just a bad luck for human beings
you know no one ever promised you a rose
garden
no one ever said who be easy to figure
out what the universe is actually doing
but if we do what we're doing right now
which is making all the observations we
can looking for gravitational waves and
there's also specific higher-order
statistical features of large-scale
structure in the universe etcetera then
one would expect in specific
inflationary models that I think
absolutely all that would count as
evidence for inflation and the absence
for it would decrease the credence that
you have that inflation is right Jacob
Gross says I was watching videos from
your movie naturalism forward conference
and was surprised by the amount of
disagreement among the speakers were you
also surprised by how heterogeneous the
views were among your contemporaries
what do you believe were the important
takeaways from the conference so I'm not
really surprised by disagreement because
why in the world would he have a
conference where you sat around agreed
with each other all the time right
there is enormous amounts of agreement
in the room but of course we didn't talk
about that so the whole point was to get
people in the room who already agreed on
crucially important questions about
naturalism right there were no
supernaturalists in the room there were
no non physicalists in the room as far
as I know people basically believe the
universe is natural it obeys the laws of
nature there's nothing outside these are
huge and questions about which we have
consensus in the room so no one was
making arguments on the base for
objective morality on the basis of God's
command or anything like that but you
don't just want to say that over and
over again you want to go to the parts
where you disagree and talk about that
so that is the whole point of that
workshop in my mind that's why it's not
called celebrating naturalism it was
called moving
naturalism forward because I get tired
of the arguments between natural ists
and theists and I want to have natural
ists
appreciate the fact that there's a whole
bunch of questions to which we don't
know the answer to which we as
naturalist have not agreed on how to
think about these questions like
freewill and consciousness and morality
so that was the whole point so I mean I
would have been very very very
disappointed if we had had a workshop
there and everyone had agreed with each
other that would have been very much
against the purpose Stephan beniker says
the Schrodinger equation is
mathematically close to the diffusion
equation is there a way to understand
this relationship in the many-worlds
interpretation so I'm sorry Stefan but
just don't know a lot about this
purported relation I have no doubt that
it's real you if you if you go into the
question in the patreon account you can
see a link that Stefan is provided to a
paper that makes the mathematical
relationship the Schrodinger equation
and the diffusion equation clear but
when you're asking the question is there
a way to understand this relationship in
the many-worlds interpretation I would
be very skeptical that many worlds
specifically has anything to say about
this because many worlds says that the
Schrodinger equation is true but so does
every other version of quantum mechanics
usually right every version of quantum
mechanics says the wave function usually
obeys the Schrodinger equation sometimes
it gets violated many world says it
never gets violated so I don't think
that there's any special insight into
why the mathematical structure of the
Schrodinger equation is close to any
other specific equation that you would
get from many worlds verses anywhere
else I could be wrong so I don't
understand a lot about this particular
claim Hector Mata says I've noticed you
mentioned David Deutsch is the fabric of
reality in your further reading for the
big picture however I also noticed you
don't mention the beginning of infinity
which overlaps a lot on it's subject
matter with the big picture Deutsch
argues against induction and rejects
Bayesian reasoning as an extension of
induction I really like Bayesian
thinking but it's really hard to argue
against Deutsch so the question is can
you help me you know I don't understand
David Deutsch is rejection of Bayesian
reasoning to be honest I'm not
SuperDuper familiar with it I read a
little bit
what he says and I just don't get it I
you know I apologize for that I don't
think that Bayesian reasoning is an
extension of induction in any way right
it's a way of getting more information
and updating your grievances I mean of
course you have to be careful here
there's bayes's theorem which everyone
agrees is a theorem of the probability
calculus okay Deutsch and everyone else
the idea basing Bayesian reasoning as a
way to learn more about the world is
just saying that these particular rules
of probability reasoning are the best
way to understand our empirical world to
me this is just obviously true so I
disagree with Deutsch about this
apparently so much so that I have
trouble understanding even what his
objection is sorry about that
Paul Hess says if we blew if we view
complexity in the universe as something
which starts low then increases and
decreases we're on that curve do we seem
to be based on the observable universe
it's very hard to say of course because
our ability to quantify complexity is
pretty meager right now I would say that
here's two arguments to give opposite
conclusions one argument is complexity
is still increasing why well just here
in our environment on earth complexity
is increasing because we're able to
build more and more complex
technological things we're still not
really surpassing organic things by very
much if at all but we can imagine doing
that in the next thousands year of years
technological development there's no
reason to suspect at all that we can't
build machines and technology that are
way more complex than human beings or
other life-forms now having said that we
are small compared to the universe so
I'm not quite sure how to quantify how
important that is so the other argument
that goes the other way is we're near
the top of the complexity curve and the
argument there is you know think about
what's happening in the universe stars
form planets form planets are where the
most complexity happens as far as we
know in the universe and the peak of
star forming the universe's history is
already passed so you can imagine that
you know it takes some time for
complexity to build up as
the first generation of stars forms they
explode the second generation has
planets and planets can have complex
life on them and things like that but
then those stars start giving out right
start burning all their nuclear fuel
fading away and that is a fade back to
equilibrium and simplicity again so I
think that on the broadest strokes
maybe we're still on the uptick a little
bit but we're pretty close to the top of
that curve would be my guess
cosmologically speaking like if you
coarse grain into bins of a hundred
million years I bet we're near the top
even ten million years Saul's Ahmet says
I feel like I come up with a solution to
Humes is ought problem and before I
start acting on it loved you tell me
where I've made a mistake so here it is
the truth of fallibilism leaves open a
possibility even if it is infinitesimal
that there is some objective source of
moral truth to be discovered or
understood if an objective if any
objective morality exists there's an
objective moral cost of taking longer to
discover it
therefore maximising knowledge is
objectively good because it increases
the chances that objective objective
moral truth is discovered I know this is
similar to Pascal's wager but I don't
think it has the same problems so let me
rephrase in case that wasn't completely
clear well I take Seoul's proposal to be
people like me think of there's no
objective morality that there's no way
to go from the reality that is objective
of what the universe is doing which is
just a bunch of stuff going on according
to laws of physics not really caring
about right and wrong too prescriptive
normative statements about good and bad
that's that's just a logical
impossibility as far as I can tell but
saul is saying well maybe you mean a
mistake in that analysis and there
really is objective good and then if we
found it it would be objectively good to
find it therefore shouldn't we look even
if it's unlikely right so that's this is
analogous to Pascal's wager which says
maybe God doesn't exist I don't know but
if God doesn't exist I can just live my
life whatever way I want if God does
exist I better believe in him because I
want to go to heaven therefore I want to
believe in God because it doesn't cost
me anything
and it might benefit me in enormous
amount
there's a lot of reasons why this kind
of reasoning isn't very good so let me
mention one in the context of Pascal's
wager and I think it will be clear where
its analogy does work in the is odd
problem of course maybe God doesn't
exist and maybe he does and if he did
you would want he wants you to sort of
pray to him and that gets you into
heaven it's also possible that maybe God
exists and God would be insulted by this
kind of dopey argument and send you for
hat to hell for believing it it's also
possible that the devil exists and is
tricking you into believing this there's
a lot of things that are possible
there'd are very unlikely according to
our best evidence and reasoning and they
might have very dramatic effects but
those effects might be the opposite of
each other
in one very very unlikely but possible
thing if you don't believe in God you go
to heaven you're sorry if you don't
believe in God you go to hell but in
another one if you don't believe in God
do you go to heaven okay there's a
million different possibilities or if
you do believe in God you're tortured
etc etc I think the conclusion from this
it's very similar to something that
Martin Rees mentioned in the podcast I
did with him maybe turning on the Large
Hadron Collider will make a black hole
that destroys the world but maybe
turning the Large Hadron Collider will
lead to a discovery that gives us free
energy forever both of these things are
incredibly incredibly unlikely so how do
you deal with them when there's a whole
bunch of unlikely things with huge
consequences I think the sensible thing
to do is to not take them very seriously
like you can't really honestly put a
very good probability of very good
credence on these being true all you can
say is they're really really unlikely so
I think that the right way to act is to
use your best logic and reason it's not
innocent right I mean the part of
Pascal's wager where it says it doesn't
hurt you to believe in God and therefore
go ahead and do it is entirely false it
certainly can hurt you to believe in God
because belief has consequences likewise
the belief in objective truth objective
good objective morality
would also have consequences what if
your objective morality said gay
marriage is bad right I mean there are
people who believe that there is
objective morality that says that that
can lead to real harm to real human
beings so I'm entirely unconvinced by
all these arguments that try to boost up
some really really really really
unlikely thing by saying well it's
harmless to believe it and its
consequences are enormous if its
consequences are enormous it's never
harmless or harmful to believe it you
should think about what it means to
believe it you should properly give it
the tiny tiny tiny fraction of
likelihood and go on with your life just
not believing that it's true Paulina
Baran says in your interview with Karl
fistin it was not quite clear to me
whether he makes a distinction between
unconscious instinctive predictions
which our brain makes all the time and
conscious rational predictions or does
he treat them all the same that's
actually a really good question I'm not
exactly sure so my guess please do not
attribute this to Karl because it's my
guess is that he's thinking of our
unconscious instinctive predictions when
he says that you know the brain works in
a certain way so as to minimize free
energy etc that is what the brain does
when it's just getting through the day
unconsciously when it's doing it's
system one kind of work when it's
actually cognitive when you're actually
consciously rationally thinking about
things I don't think that there is any
analogous free energy argument you can
override almost any simple kind of
minimization procedure not to say
there's not a minimization procedure but
it'd be a complicated one not something
simple like free energy Johnny says in
Dragon Ball Z they have gravity chambers
where the gravity is set higher allowing
them to train there and become much
stronger when going back to normal
gravity is there any merit to that idea
in the real world or is it just silly so
I mean there is merit to the idea that
if you could train in a region with
higher gravity it might make you
stronger in exactly the same way as
training carrying weights makes you
stronger right if what you're asking is
could you build a gravity chamber like
that there's two different answers one
is no you cannot really build a gravity
chamber like that you cannot manipulate
the strength of grad
according to Einstein's general
relativity the strength of gravity is
directly tied to the mass of the earth
and you cannot you know move around
masses comparable to the earth so that
they only affect what's going on inside
a little chamber and not outside gravity
is not manipulable in the way in that
way as for instance electricity and
magnetism are manipulatable in that way
the difference is that in enm you have
both positive charges and negative
charges and by carefully arranging the
distribution of positive and negative
charges you can make whatever
electromagnetic field you want and
gravity you only have positive charges
every particle in the universe creates
more gravity so all you can do is
increase the amount of gravity by
bringing more stuff together now having
said that you could mimic it in a
centrifuge right you could mimic it by
taking a room putting it on a sort of
pendulum and swinging it around really
fast because Einstein also says that
acceleration and gravity are very
related to each other so just accelerate
something and that would be just like
having more gravity an anonymous
commenter says I recall you saying that
you learned about the many-worlds
interpretation before bells inequality
that was surprising to me in popular
science land bells inequality is one of
the first things you learned about
quantum mechanics where did you learn
about many worlds when did you decide it
was probably right I don't remember
exactly when I first learned about many
worlds I know that I was thinking about
it at a scientific level at least in
graduate school by the time I got to
graduate school I was thinking about
cosmology you know this is circa 1990
and one of the hot topics was Euclidean
quantum gravity and Sidney Coleman's
idea that you could use wormholes in
Euclidean quantum gravity to understand
the vanishing of the vacuum energy and
quantum cosmology more generally was a
hot topic back in those days and
essentially almost everyone who does
quantum cosmology believes in the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics so I went completely along
with that I had no idea that there were
any sensible alternatives I had strong
feelings that the usual Copenhagen story
made no sense and that many worlds
seemed to make sense but I did not
really appreciate that there
were still viable theories of hidden
variables or dynamical collapse or
anything like that
Ramon Roca says I've been reading a bit
about brane cosmology that's B R a and E
brane a common theme is that no
experimental or observational evidence
exists for extra dimensions if we were
Flatlanders living on a plane
intersecting a 3d object or living on
its surface
what sort of experiments can be
performed to reveal that the true 3d
shape of what we perceive of as a 2d
universe well the simplest answer is
gravity okay I mean this is one of the
great things about gravity is it can't
be confined to a two dimensional brane
so if we really did live in so let's say
just to get my own talking about this
sensible we live in three-dimensional
space
okay so let's manage me live in a
three-dimensional space embedded in a
four-dimensional world how would you
know well and I don't mean four
dimensional space-time you mean embedded
in four dimensional space well gravity
would leak out into that extra fourth
dimension of space that would mean that
the Newtonian law of gravity would not
be an inverse square law it would be an
inverse cubed law so the reason why
gravity's inverse square is because the
gravitational lines of force spread out
and dilute as the distance squared
because we live in three-dimensional
space if gravity really escaped into
four-dimensional space it would spread
out faster that's the empirical way that
we can do it and in fact if you believe
that there was an extra dimension or two
extra dimensions and they were very
small you could do experiments testing
Newton's inverse square law and people
have done that most famously Eric Idle
Burger has collaborators in the 8th wash
experiment at the University of
Washington to the best of our empirical
knowledge space seems to be three
dimensional all the way down Simon
Carter says I think he once joked that
if grw this is a spontaneous collapse
theory of quantum mechanics was proved
true that you would leave physics but if
that does turn out to be right or some
other theory other than many worlds
would you be able to just take it on the
chin and move on sure it was just a joke
I would be able to go and chin no matter
what reality does and I think that every
physicist is like that
of course we have preferences we have
beliefs we have credence 'as we have our
favourite theories but whatever nature
does nature's doing something cool cuz
nature is just cool by definition so if
nature is doing grw or dynamical
collapse then that would be really
really interesting in all sorts of ways
my joke was to make clear to everyone
who was listening that in my view you
know many worlds is is definitely the
leader by a long shot
things like hidden variable theories
make sense to me I don't think they
really fit the world in which we live
but if some better version of them came
along that would be ok I would get it
but something where the wavefunction is
randomly collapses just seems horrible
to me I would learn to adapt yes but I
put out much smaller credence on that
theory than I do on hidden variable
theories for example has an alternative
to many worlds Christian Cosentino says
your answer to my previous question
regarding many worlds was that when the
universe divides it doesn't create a new
universe but divides the existing one
into two since this potentially happens
billions and billions of times will we
ever run out of universe so no we're
never gonna run out of universe sorry
let me let me let me be a little bit
more precise about that there's two and
I talk about this a lot in the book in
something deeply hidden if you want a
longer discussion of it I talked about
exactly this using exactly these words
so the difference is is Hilbert space is
the space of all possible wave functions
finite dimensional or infinite
dimensional if it's infinite dimensional
then no we will never run out of
different ways the universe can branch
we have an infinite amount of room in
which to move and that's very possible
it's also very possible that he'll
precise is finite dimensional and in
that case you will have a maximum number
of splittings you can possibly do but
you don't run out of universe that's why
I quickly said you don't run out of
universe rather the splitting stops
happening right in order for branching
to happen in the way that we know about
it certain conditions have to be met the
environment the space of things that we
don't keep track of in our quantum wave
function has to be much much larger than
the space of the classical things is
classical approximately classical things
that we do keep track of and that will
eventually stop to be true far in the
future of the universe once we approach
thermal equilibrium so this approach to
effectively running out in the quantum
sense classically it looks like we're
approaching thermal equilibrium which
will eventually happen right the stars
will burn out the black holes will
evaporate 10 to the 100 years from now
things are gonna look like thermal
equilibrium branching of the
wavefunction in the usual way we
understand it will no longer happen
James O'Sullivan says in the last AMA I
asked for clarification on the double
slit experiment why a particles
interaction with the slits doesn't cause
decoherence you said that the double
slit experiment is an idealization and
that we need to imagine the states of
the particles can you elaborate on what
is actually done in the lab then so I
think I said what you need to do is
imagine the states of the slits not just
the particles which we never do and when
we talk about the double slit experiment
I cannot elaborate on what is actually
done in the lab this is a complicated
question okay that you know
experimentalists or highly trained
professionals and I'm not one of them I
can if you really really are interested
I can recommend reading a book by
yuckier Aronov and collaborators called
quantum paradoxes or quantum puzzles
something like that basically he goes
through a long list chapter by chapter
of these kinds of questions right like
so he talks about the double slit
experiment in great detail and he does
it in a very sensible way he says what
if you had these slits but you put the
slits on wheels so that when the
electron goes through one slit or the
other it can actually nudge the slits
back and forth this is a way you can
actually model the interaction with the
slits then you can talk about the wave
function for that table and of course it
depends on details is the answer but
it's all work out a bowl I can show you
that mark Tyrion says I find it an
equally difficult conceptual leap to
think of space emerging out of quantum
entanglement as time flowing relative to
fixed cardinal points instead of left to
right does understanding the math make
the former easier for you to
imagine can math be a language that
makes ideas like this conceivable I
think the different physicists and
different mathematicians have different
approaches to conceptualizing these
difficult ideas I'm actually more visual
than most people I do try to visualize
things but if you're really doing this
math at a deep level you can't rely on
the ability to visualize things you know
when you say that oh there's a hilbert
space that has a dimensionality of 10 to
the 10 to the 123 and someone says well
how do you visualize that you don't
visualize it you visualize it by
imagining it has a dimensionality of 3
and then there's a lot more that you're
not seeing that's really all you can do
it's a it's hideously inadequate to the
task so but what you can do which is
implied in your question is you can
trust the math right if I understand the
math for two or three dimensional
hilbert spaces then the extension to
google upon google dimensional hilbert
spaces should just be a matter of
trusting the math it would be very
helpful to be able to visualize these
other things but I can't do it no one
else can do it either we got to do the
best we can do Zachary Roland says have
you ever had a serious talk with Lee
Smolin I've been following both of your
research and was a believer in max type
marks mathematical universe however upon
pondering girdle's theorem I find it
very hard to believe that there can be a
mathematical framework in the real
universe when we know there are holes in
the math we're working with so I'm not
sure what is the relationship of the
different parts of your question here
sure I've had plenty of serious talks
with Lee Smolin we've been at
conferences together we've talked
together a lot about various different
things
I really don't I'm not quite seeing what
this how this relates to the
mathematical universe question but I
don't think of hand that girdle's
theorem is an obstacle to Max's
mathematical universe idea Max's idea is
that every mathematical structure is
real there's a really existing universe
corresponding to every such mathematical
structure girdle's incompleteness
theorem is about provably true
statements namely that any sufficiently
powerful formal system will have
statements
cannot be proven true but are true if
the formal system is consistent but I
don't think that the proved ability of
statements plays an important role in
Max's theory maybe it does and I'm just
missing something there Sandro Stuckey
says you've said earlier the quantum
field theories are typically developed
by quantizing a classical field theory
so I guess there may be a classical
electron field corresponding to that in
QED does this field show up somewhere in
classical electrodynamics so the answer
is it could you know there is a
classical electron field that you can
write down you can write down the
equation for it the equation is called
the Dirac equation that's what it is the
Dirac equation is precisely the equation
obeyed by a non interacting classical
electron field the problem is and it's
not a huge problem but it's the reason
why you never hear about it is because
the classical field doesn't do a very
good job of approximating the real world
behavior right the classical
electromagnetic field is a really good
approximation to quantum electrodynamics
whereas the classical electron field is
not and the reason why is because of the
poly exclusion principle the exclusion
principle says you can't have two
particles of the electron form of Fermi
on fields doing exactly the same thing
so that makes classical matter fields
classical Fermi on fields just not be
very good approximation to anything you
don't pile up many many many electrons
doing the same thing to get classical
behavior so instead when you do
classical electrodynamics you model the
electron as a point charge but even
though you know that what it really is
is a quantum mechanical vibration in the
electron field
there's just no overlap between the
regime where the classical electron
field description would work in the real
world
Dmitri Puka Schaub says you were talking
about how space-time could actually be
emergent from the Everett theory does
this reasoning also apply to quantum
field theory could it be derived from
the evolution of the universal
wavefunction that's the hope
absolutely you know we absolutely would
like it to be the case
that someday we will derive not just
gravity in space-time but quantum field
theory and the standard model etc from
entanglement properties and the behavior
of the universal wavefunction having
done that yet plenty of work to be done
for young prospective graduate students
out there John Reynolds says we
understand that the Cosmic Microwave
Background has a temperature we also
understand this temperature was hotter
in the past and will be colder in the
future if it was possible to measure
this temperature and its rate of change
accurately enough would this not be the
ultimate perfect clock tied directly to
the entropy of the universe so two
things it three things number one it's
an okay clock it is a clock right a
clock is just something that
distinguishes between different moments
of time the temperature of the Cosmic
Microwave Background does that because
the universe expands number two it's not
a perfect clock because if you want a
perfect clock you need to be have
infinite resolution between different
moments of time but when you measure the
temperature of something you're waiting
for photons to hit your thermometer or
whatever it takes time to do a reading
there's no sense in which you have
infinitely fine gradations in the
moments of time and you'll be measuring
by measuring the temperature of the CMB
and the final thing is it is not tied
directly to the entropy of the universe
because if you were in a universe that
was nothing but Cosmic Microwave
Background the entropy of that universe
wouldn't be changing as it was expanding
and the universe was cooling the
temperature of the microwave background
would be decreasing but the volume be
increasing and the effects would cancel
out and you can sort of intuitively get
that by remembering that it's reversible
right if you expand the universe the
microwave background photons cool off if
you contract it they heat up in exactly
the same way it's a reversible process
so no entropy is being either created or
destroyed along the way Eric Vern lick
says we're won't lick a much word
is there a reason time must be conceived
as a single dimension when a quantum
event causes the universe to split into
many worlds theory could you think of
them as each being a separate temporal
dimension
I mean empirically time is a single
dimension
right like I can move different
directions in space I can't move
different directions sometime that's it
mathematically we could write down
models of the universe in which there is
more than one time dimension those
models don't look anything like the
world in which we live when you say the
universe is splitting can you think of
them as each being a separate temporal
dimension I don't think so there's one
equation the Schrodinger equation and
that equation has the letter T in it for
time and that time keeps track of the
time in all the branches of the
wavefunction the same in the same way so
time this time that is moving on
different branches of the wavefunction
is the same time not separate time
dimensions Schurman flips says the
delayed choice quantum eraser experiment
showed an interesting way in which
decoherence can be manipulated
experimentally with decoherence now as
more of a known factor can we use
whether it happens or not to determine
interesting things about systems by
substituting them for the eraser in the
experimental apparatus is this what
quantum computing is so I don't think so
man I might be misunderstanding the
question here a little bit
the thing about decoherence in the
quantum eraser etc is there's no
experimental surprises right like the
delayed choice quantum eraser has been
worked out theoretically what should
happen and when they tried to do it in
the lab that's what happens there's
nothing that we're learning about
quantum mechanics other than that it
continues to be right it's the same
quantum theory that was written down in
the 1920s right we didn't need to modify
quantum mechanics or our understanding
of it to take into account decoherence
or the delayed choice quantum eraser or
whatever and I don't think that anything
would be different if we replace the
eraser with something else
you know we there might not be things we
understand about a certain material
system but it's not quantum mechanics
we're learning about as far as quantum
computing quantum computing tries to
avoid decoherence as long as possible so
that you can keep things in
superposition in the process of the
quantum computation but again you know
you need to learn about matter about the
stuff that is making up your Cuba
but you're not learning anything
especially novel about the fundamental
rules of quantum theory along the way
Adrian Perez says hey Sean you've
probably been the biggest influence on
my philosophy oh thank you Adrian seems
like yesterday I was sitting at home
after high school watching your
naturalism lecture on YouTube just
wanted to know who is that person for
you if you have one I don't think I have
one I built up my philosophical beliefs
from all sorts of sources I didn't
discover philosophy has a formal subject
until I was in college until I went to
Villanova and they had requirements
these are back in the days he had lots
of core course requirements so he had to
take three semesters of philosophy as
well as three semesters of religious
studies which was quasi philosophical
and I liked it and liked it and liked it
more and learned more about it but there
was never a moment of you know one big
person or one big philosophy grabbing my
attention I mean different people's
personalities are different my
personality is kind of anti individual
idolizing of anybody for anything other
than Julius Erving for playing
basketball other than that I think that
we should be pluralistic and willing to
give up on people as we learn more about
them and we learn that they're not who
we thought they were and we should be
willing to increase people in our esteem
if we learn more things about them that
are admirable Jamie Laurie says I like
the Roger Ebert quote the cinema is a
machine for creating empathy but it made
me think listening to podcast with
incredibly smart people is a
dunning-kruger machine I love listening
to your podcast but I think I understand
quantum mechanics in the way my dog
understands English as a science
communicator is there any technology you
can conceive that would really make a
difference in bridging the comprehensive
gap for the non-technical audience so
yes that technology is called the book
if you really want to understand this
stuff it's just no way of understanding
physics theories without understanding
the mathematical basis of them but
that's understandable it just takes work
it just takes time there is no Royal
Road to geometry as Euclid is I think it
was Euclid
was supposed to have said to his royal
tutti you have to learn the math you
have to learn the physics you can learn
them through books you can learn them
through online courses the books are
there the courses are there it's there
for everybody there's just no shortcut
however at the same time I want to say
that I'm sure you understand quantum
mechanics better than your dog
understands English your dog understands
a little bit of English right some
commands but we can conceptually
understand parts of physics even if we
don't understand the math what we can't
do is manipulate them we can't solve the
equations and find out what's going to
happen in the way that a professional
can Ezra pars a Bock says is there a
grand is a grand unified theory
inevitable or is it possible that it is
a brute fact that the math for QED and
the math for gravity will never add up
to a grand unified theory so just so
everyone knows the phrase grand unified
theory is a technical term within
physics which does not include gravity
the idea of a grand unified theory is a
theory that includes electromagnetism
the weak nuclear force and the strong
nuclear force this was the big goal in
the 1970s and some of the 80s to find
such a theory the idea of putting
gravity into it just didn't wasn't there
that seemed too hard
it wasn't until string theory came along
and really string theory became popular
in the mid 80s the first superstring
revolution 1984 that's when people began
to think that they might honestly be
able to include gravity along with all
the other forces of nature and the
technical term as it were for that is a
theory of everything so I think what
you're asking is will will is a theory
of everything inevitable and I think the
answer is yes it clearly is inevitable
because the theory of everything is just
whatever the correct description of
nature is and I mean nature exists
nature is doing something whatever the
correct description of that is is the
theory of everything
it might not be elegant or simple it
might look ontological II nothing like
what we're familiar with or it might we
just don't know but the existence of the
universe is evidence for the existence
of a descript
the universe and therefore the theory
must be there Brent Meeker says how
would sterile neutrinos fit into the
standard model would they have enough
rest mass to be dark matter so sterile
neutrinos are a hypothetical form of
neutrino that doesn't interact with the
weak nuclear force like regular
neutrinos do it's not hard to modify the
standard model to put sterile neutrinos
in there could they have enough rest
mass to be dark matter it's not one of
the more popular candidates but I
believe please don't quote me on this
but I believe that you can come up with
theories in which sterile neutrinos are
the dark matter
Alex Co sin Co at UCLA is one of the
world's experts in neutrino physics and
he can use neutrinos to explain anything
as long as you believe in certain
neutrino properties so I think there's a
wide window open for neutrinos to
explain things like dark matter as well
as other things robber trucks and rescue
says I would like to know exactly how
exactly does a photon interact with an
electron considering the two of them are
waves are we guaranteed to have a
collision between the two in the
particle way of thinking well I think
the point is that the particle way of
thinking is not very good if you want to
really zoom in on what's happening
during an interaction of the photon with
the electron if you believed that both
electrons and photons were truly
particle-like then the chances the two
particles which by definition have zero
size would literally hit each other
would be zero right it's a set of
measure zero the trajectories that in
which those two things would intersect
so at the very least you should not
treat the photon as exactly particle
like away the photon has a wavelength
and things like that so maybe you can
say you could treat the electron as a
particle but really you should just do
it right I mean neither the electron or
the photon are actually particles their
vibrations in waves and they interact
when they overlap and that can be
overlapping to a greater or lesser
extent and then there's a greater or
lesser probability that you will observe
them
scatter off of each other Thomas Prunty
says a question was asked last week
maybe that means last month about
arriving at home arriving it's the same
answer by different means in physics I
wonder what part of my subconscious made
me say arriving at home sorry about that
about arriving at the same answer by
different means in physics this reminded
me of a different case the Einstein a B
coefficients and the rate of spontaneous
emission it was calculated originally by
Einstein using thermodynamic arguments
and basic quantum mechanics even though
as I understand it spontaneous emission
relies fundamentally on quantum field
theory and was only later calculated
from first principles in QED are they
really two fundamentally different ways
of arriving at the same answer or are
they actually the same somehow I'm gonna
prevaricate a little bit here because
it's been literally decades since I've
looked at the calculation of Einstein a
B coefficients in any details that was
when I was taking a quantum course in
graduate school but I think basically
there it's not quite the same as two
fundamentally different ways of getting
the same answer because the answer
you're getting or slightly different
things
Einstein was trying to understand a way
in which various stochastic processes
interacted and happened in the same
environment in order to give an answer
that we saw in experiments right whereas
the quantum field theory thing is saying
you know exactly what this microscopic
situation is of this particular atom and
this particular electron and let's ask
what happens next I would say they're
complementary but the questions that
they're asking and answering are not
exactly the same so it's not really an
example of two fundamentally different
ways of arriving at the same answer Paul
Hardy says can you explain what the
transactional view of quantum physics is
I watched a video with Ruth Kastner
explaining it but did not understand it
so no I cannot explain that one either
sorry about that I'm just not familiar
I've heard people mention it before it's
not very clear to me what it actually
said sorry about that
Razia med says let's assume you were
creating an entropic score of
intelligence you might put ESI you might
put Laplace's deamon towards one end of
the scale with an ESI of one you might
argue the demon has no intrinsic under
of anything what would you put on the
other end of the scale what a species
with ESI of zero be one that is able to
encapsulate all laws of physics in a few
characters so I'm gonna apologize here
also because I don't exactly know what
you mean by this entropic score of
intelligence
it seems vaguely related to a level of
coarse graining right Laplace is demon
visualizes the world in a maximally
fine-grained way it knows every little
detail about everything you and I
observe the world in a coarse-grained
way even when we look at the table right
in front of us we don't see the
microscopic state of it we see some
macroscopic observable properties so
Laplace is demon I've often said in some
sense doesn't need to know about ideas
like entropy and temperature these are
higher-level emergent phenomena Laplace
is demon only needs to know the
microscopic level it could like you know
the pasta demon is made up it's
imaginary we could imagine a version of
Laplace's demon that knew about emergent
properties like entropy and temperature
we can also imagine people like us that
only know about entropy and temperature
and do not know through our everyday
senses through our eyes and ears the
locations of any fundamental particles
but if that's the scale you're using
then the maximally coarse-grained
observable is just the universe
expressed as a single number okay I
don't know what that number is maybe
it's average density or something like
that so someone tells you that number
it's 5 that gives you nothing right that
gives you no information about anything
at all that's in the nature of coarse
graining as your coarse graining becomes
more and more coarse you have less and
less microscopic information so in the
transition from completely fine grained
to increasingly coarse grained there are
some useful places to be in some non
useful places to be maximally coarse
grained is not a useful place to be
minimally coarse grained that is to say
maximally fine grained where you know
every detail that is a useful place to
be in principle but in practice is
completely useless you don't have the
storage capacity to actually work that
way so there are different layers in
between where you actually get some
useful ability to predict what will have
been empirically on the basis of
incomplete information but the actual
places where that is is very very
detailed and hard to predict what that
would be I mean we find it out
empirically we don't predict it from
first principles and I really don't know
what it would even mean to relate this
to some kind of score of intelligence
Sean K Davis says I find myself
wondering if you think there is a rock
bottom to reality if so what do you
think that rock bottom might be so yes I
mean related to the previous question I
think that nature itself by construction
is the rock bottom to reality maybe what
you mean is is there a complete
comprehensive theory of reality and
again yes for exactly the same reasons
maybe what you mean is does that
complete theory of reality have the form
of a theory of really really tiny things
interacting with each other and that we
don't know that we have no idea that's
not what my favorite idea would be right
my favorite idea would be something like
the rock bottom theory is the wave
function of the universe a vector in
hilbert space and all the talk that we
have of space and particles and fields
and interactions is a merchant at some
higher level but that I have no
confidence that that's right we have no
way of knowing how close we are to the
final theory of all the stuff that makes
up the reality Jake Johansen says if a
quantum computer has to measure the
state of a qubit before it can use it
computationally how is that any
different than a classical bit well it
doesn't so this is important a quantum
computer has to measure the state of the
qubits that it outputs but when a
quantum computer is manipulating the
qubits when it's actually doing the
calculation it's never measuring
anything measuring things collapse their
wave function and that's stochastic and
random and unpredictable the whole point
of the quantum computer is to maintain
quantum coherence not measure anything
not collapse anything do everything
deterministically output a set of qubits
and then measure those and the property
will be that you try to outfit a set of
output a set
of qubits with the property that when
you measure them they tell you the right
answer to the calculation you're doing
with very very very high probability
hopefully you can get that probability
high enough to be useful
Peter Bamber says if you had to move
from fundamental physics to Applied
Physics what area what do you think
would attract you and why so I'm
actually working more these days in non
equilibrium statistical mechanics this
is an interest that came out of my
interest in entropy and bayes's theorem
and things like that and also complexity
theory this is a kind of Applied Physics
I don't know whether or not how you
should exactly characterize it because
what we're doing is looking for very
robust rules obeyed by complex systems
complex statistical mechanical systems
so it's a kind of fundamental physics
but I think that there's a more
traditional definition of fundamental
physics where you're looking at
elementary particles and fields not at
composite objects like complex systems
okay so that's what I would do in fact
that is what I'm doing to a greater
extent that I was before Kellan Rivers
says what is your opinion of Trump's
response to the corona virus pandemic
including the two trillion-dollar
stimulus package I don't have any
detailed feelings about the stimulus
package I have no idea whether Donald
Trump gets any credit if at all for that
it went through Congress there's a lot
that goes into how the sausage is made
when a stimulus package like that gets
passed through Congress I'm sure that
all sorts of representatives and
Senators on both parties put their
special things into the package as much
as they could once two trillion dollars
is going through the pipeline skimming
off a billion here a billion there
doesn't seem that hard right I do think
we need some kind of stimulus package as
I said elsewhere my own preference would
be to give it to poor people to give it
to people who would spend the money just
give people cash let them keep the
economy going by circulating that cash
if you give money to people who will
spend it then people who are not poor
will quickly get the money because
they're owning the companies on which
it's spent right so I really want you my
real fear
in the corona virus epidemic aside from
the obvious health fears the figure of
getting sick and dying and other people
dying are small businesses and for my
own personal reasons small restaurants
and pubs and bars and things like that
entertainment venues the kind of things
that make our lives colorful and
enjoyable when things are going well
small restaurants especially it's just
gonna be so hard for them to survive
this and I think that's a terrible
tragedy and I wish that more were being
done to stop it in terms of stopping the
epidemic the pandemic
I think the Trump has done a terrible
terrible job mostly by neglect by not
taking it seriously early on and by
early on I mean you know years before we
had any idea that the pandemic was going
to hit he's a short term thinker he
dismantled the pandemic response team in
the CDC etc he slashed funding for
dealing with these kinds of unlikely but
terrible emergencies and we are feeling
it the United States is now the
epicenter of the pandemic we have more
cases than anybody else you don't know
that for sure because maybe other
countries are not reporting accurately
but certainly it is very very bad
getting worse very very rapidly and to
some extent it's our fault both a lack
of preparation and a lack of dealing
with it quickly when it happened
Ricardo Rose era says do you think the
hard problem of consciousness is an
actual problem whenever I hear someone
talk about it I always conclude that it
is just a bad question caused by
thinking that a philosophical zombie is
plausible so I do think that it's a it's
a real problem in the sense that it is
ok to ask the question the hard problem
of consciousness being how do you
account for first-person subjective
experiences the redness of red you know
the things that you can feel but not
really communicate to somebody else but
I don't think it's hard in the sense of
the kinds of explanations for those
things are going to be fundamentally
conceptually distinct from the kinds of
explanations that we have in the case of
the easy problem like why do you see the
color red why do you are why are you
able to recognize the red of a stop sign
as being distinct from the green of a
green light I don't think there's
anything spooky about our first person
experiences I don't think you need to
step outside the usual way of explaining
things I think eventually what will
happen is you'll understand what happens
in the brain when you have those
experiences and we will call that
understanding the answer to the hard
problem Marianne mark Holly says can we
have the tiniest controllable
singularity in orbit to be used as a
mega battery so no I don't think so for
one thing you don't have singularities
right there's something called the
cosmic censorship conjecture put forward
by Roger Penrose previous mindscape
guest which says that whenever there's a
singularity in nature it's surrounded by
an event horizon so really what you have
is a black hole right and event horizon
surrounding a singularity and black
holes by themselves are not batteries
there's if you have a black hole that is
not spinning there's no way to get
energy out of it it's in its lowest
energy state given its its macroscopic
parameters it is it is in its highest
entropy State let's put it that way
given its mass so it's not a battery in
any realistic sense if you have a
spinning black hole that is an energy
source that you can extract energy from
in principle that is also something it
was invented by Roger Penrose called the
Penrose process if you want to look it
up in practice we have no idea how to do
that and also in practice a smaller
black hole will be much harder to
extract energy from from than a large
black hole large black holes even though
they're larger are actually milder
outside there's a milder gravitational
field outside so it'd be easier to
extract energy from a large black hole
than a big one but even a black hole the
mass of the Sun is small by these
conditions so you would have to
introduce into the solar system an
entirely new solar sized object to even
start talking about this I don't
recommend that as a way to go Robert
Gustafson says is the ability to learn a
new behavior something genetic or
something environmental given the answer
to that question how do we induce people
to think critically before they act or
speak more often I'm not exactly sure
what you mean
exactly sure how to distinguish the
genetic and environmental features of
the ability to learn new behavior I mean
many things have abilities to learn new
behaviors right people cats computers
you know simple machines have the in
some sense ability to learn new
behaviors computers don't even have
genetics right but they can still learn
new behaviors so if the second part of
your question is a more important one
how can we induce people to think
critically you know people are
complicated mixtures of reason and
irrationality and I think that you know
it's it's it's sort of a little bit
starting off on the wrong foot to say
like all those people are not thinking
critically but I am right none of us
thinks critically all the time none of
us is irrational all the time what we
should do is try to overall increase the
amount of rationality in the world and
we can do that by understanding what it
means to be rational ourselves by being
examples of good reason by helping
people out who want to learn more
critically to think better and more
rationally Spencer Hargis says let's say
you commit the perfect crime a crime
pulled off so unbelievably smoothly that
the world where you committed the crime
looks exactly like the one where you
didn't in every way down to subatomic
precision with any sort of interference
happen between the world where you were
guilty and the one where you were
innocent
so I'm Spencer I'm going to uh nask this
question because I just don't think it
is a sensible scenario that you've
outlined here if you really are
imagining that I measure some quantum
system like an electron and see the spin
up or spin down and if it's spin up I
commit a crime if it's spin down I don't
and I commit the crime in such a way
that I'm affecting the world around me
minimally so that I try not to branch
the wave function of the universe I
think that's literally inconceivable
because just by existing I'm radiating
right just by breathing and living I'm
giving off infrared radiation and if I
give it off in a different location in
two different branches of the universe
that's instantly more than enough
to disturb the universe enormous li and
to branch the wavefunction very very
obviously so the thought experiment in
which I as a macroscopic person do two
separate things in two different parts
of the wavefunction and yet those wave
those parts the wavefunction do not
branch and stop interfering is not one
that makes a lot of sense to me
Sam Hartzog says I recently came across
an article in physics world that equated
climate change policy to making a
Pascal's wager second Pascal's wager
questioned this AMA awesome I've been a
naturalist three years now and I wasn't
persuaded by Pascal's wager
unfortunately I didn't find the popular
refutations wholly convincing either if
we further remove the association with
Christianity the wager seems to reduce
to an incredibly tiny possibility of
upside versus no risk whatsoever in that
case the rational choice seems to be the
tiny potential for upside no matter how
remote so as I said to the earlier
question number one there's never no
risk whatsoever by the lights of the
thought experiment you're saying yes yes
yes I know that something is very
unlikely but imagine that it has a tiny
possibility being true so if you say
that for one thing like the existence of
God or the existence of objective
morality you should also say it for
other things like the existence of the
devil or the fact that if we discovered
objective morality maybe everybody would
die you know maybe there's some terrible
terrible thing that would happen by
doing that so that's the problem with
all of these wagers is you can't just
say there's no risk to believing this
because there always is either there
either the thing you're believing has
literally no impact on how you behave in
any way or there is a risk to believing
in so I'm in favor of ignoring these
Pascal wagers kinds of arguments
Anthony Tonkin says coronavirus is
having a massive impact on the world but
what are some things you identify as
being positive things we learn from it
when we get to look back on it years
from now I think besides pandemic
preparedness vaccine technology there
will be at least some sense of data for
what a universal income would start to
look like and also by the way maybe
coincidentally Yan Liu Scheck right
afterwards
do you think there is any upside to the
current kovat 19 crisis will society
change for the better in any way as a
result of the situation in your opinion
you know I want to say two things seems
to be a pattern in my answers here today
sure there will be some upsides to this
you know we'll learn something by
studying it will be jolted out of our
complacency about this particular kind
of unlikely but but frightening ly
plausible disaster scenario so yeah
pandemic preparedness for instance will
probably be greater ten years from now
than it was ten years ago but you know
on the other hand the other part of the
answer is I'm not that interested in
looking at the upsides right now you
know we have to get through it I think
that you can look at the upsides but
there's a danger that you it's very hard
to balance them correctly right I mean
obviously the downsides are hugely
enormous so the temptation to say yes
but there's also an upside it's just
really really hard to say that in a
reasonable way that doesn't downplay the
fact that this is mostly downside that
we're facing now so you know I don't
want to say that you shouldn't think
about it or whatever you should always
think about anything you want to think
about I'm in favor of that but I
personally am NOT going to spend much
time wondering about the upsides I'm
sure they will be there we will learn
things but the downsides are so big that
that's where my attention is gonna be
focused Abdul loves all says and one
criticism that is often and now I'm
coughing
trust me I'm coughing because I've been
doing nama for hours not because I'm in
any way ill Abdul loves all says one
criticism that is often cited against
many worlds is a commitment to assigning
ontological status to the quantum state
and hence Hilbert space assuming you
take this to be a bug do you think
introduction of primitive ontology to
many worlds solves this problem or the
critics missing something so I don't
take it to be a bug sorry about that I
think that even within the world of
people who take many worlds seriously I
am much more fundamentalist about the
ontology of many world so for those of
you who don't know what we're talking
about
ontology is the study of being what is
the fundamental stuff that you have in
your theory many-worlds is the simplest
answer to that question it's just a
wavefunction and nothing else the
quantum state that's the ontology other
theories like hidden variables have
other variables other parts of reality
in addition to the wavefunction and what
is a wavefunction so there's different
versions of the ant's of ways you can
answer that question some people think
of a wave function as a function of a
set of other variables so even though
the only physics is in the wave function
it's a wave function of something like
the positions of a bunch of particles or
the value of a bunch of fields or
something like that I don't even think
that I think the wave functions is a
vector in Hilbert space . this is what
ash Meads sing and I wrote a paper on
which we called mad dog Eveready anism
this is named after mad dog naturalism
which is the theory of Alex Rosenberg
who's another previous mindscape guest
so mad dog a beretti anism takes the
absolutely minimal version of ontology
just a vector in a really big big big
hilbert space and tries to show how the
evolution of that vector through time
can give rise to the emergent world
around us so I don't think it's a bug I
think it's a wonderful feature plenty of
work to be done though in connecting it
to reality Jeremy Labrecque says if
measuring a quantum vent with a binary
outcome leads to a splitting of the wave
function does measuring something with
the distribution such as a location of
electron lead to a spreading of the wave
function as in it spreads into a
distribution of worlds where the
electron was observed in different
places yeah basically that is correct if
you have variables with continuous
possible observational outcomes like the
position of an electron in
nonrelativistic quantum mechanics then
it's impossible to say there are a
certain fixed number of worlds at any
one moment of time what there is are
there are different worlds but they are
smoothly distributed so it's it's
absolutely sensible to say that the
electron is measured here in one world
and they're in another world but it does
not make sense in this context to say
well how many worlds are there in
between
it's just a fuzzy kind of delineation
that once again the math is perfectly
sensible but the language the verb the
verbiage that we have in English to talk
about this is not quite up to the task
but yes there will be a smooth
distribution of worlds in this picture
Greg right says do you think of
emergence as something that happens in
the world when matter and energy reaches
certain complexity to bring about
additional levels of organization or as
emergent something that happens in human
brains as they reorganize more and more
complex phenomena into describable
concepts that can be manipulated
independently so I don't think quite
either one emergence nut doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with
complexity right thermodynamics the
study of temperature and heat and
pressure and fluid mechanics right this
is a standard example of emergence and
there's no complexity involved
whatsoever things could be completely in
thermal equilibrium and still have this
emergent description of themselves but
it's also just not in the human brain
emergence a very very specific thing
that happens when you're able to predict
the behavior of a physical system on the
basis of way less information than
actually in here's in that system that
happens sometimes in physical reality
but usually not okay usually if you want
to predict what a system with a lot of
particles is gonna do you need to know
what all the particles are going to do
to find situations where you only need
to know certain very specific pieces of
information in order to make reliable
predictions is incredibly precious and
rare and that's when emergence happens
but it's also objectively real when it
happens it usually doesn't happen but
when it does we can tell we can do
experiments to see it at work
Massimiliano Megara says my question is
which is currently your favorite theory
to explain consciousness and why you
know I'd say I don't really have a
favorite theory to explain consciousness
as I explained in the big picture I
think that you know the goal of that
book even though I talk about
consciousness a lot the goal is not to
explain consciousness my goal in that
book it's a very good goal to try to
explain consciousness but that's not
what I was trying to do what I was
trying to do was simply to say there is
essential
no reason to doubt that whatever the
explanation is it will be on the basis
of naturalism you do not need to bring
anything in that is supernatural or even
non-physical to explain consciousness
the actual way that it works I don't
know
right I mean there's there's that's like
saying what is my favorite theory of
dark matter there's lots of different
theories of dark matter whichever one is
is true or even if one that we haven't
thought of yet is true that's fine with
me
but I'm sure the dark matter is some
kind of matter that has the basic
features we think it has likewise with
consciousness Christoph Pierre on Suki
says if dark energy is a property of
space itself and causes it to expand
then it seems that energy is increasing
with expanding space ie is not conserved
I am sure there is a mistake in this
argument do not be so sure Christophe
there is no mistake in that argument
there's if you go on to google and type
in energy is not conserved the first or
one of the first things will come up is
a blog post that I wrote several years
ago about this very fact that when you
have general relativity and you have a
dynamical changing space-time our usual
notion of energy is just not conserved
now you can mess with our usual notion
of energy you can try to change the
definition of it to get something that
is conserved but I think it's just
easier to say that the feature that we
used to have with space and time being
absolute and unchanging was what gave
rise to conservation of energy
once space-time is changing there's no
reason to think that energy is conserved
it still obeys a law there's still a
rule that says exactly what happens to
the energy as space expands so it's not
like all craziness as breaking booze
broken booze it's just that the law is a
little bit of a generalization of the
flat space example Paul toric says if
you're familiar with Mark Stuckey
Michael Silberstein and Timothy
McDevitt's relational Bloch world
interpretation of quantum mechanics can
you give us a quick opinion on it no I'm
not and no I can't
sorry about that I've never heard of
that one there's a lot of theories out
there that I'm not familiar
with Ronald Goran says with all you do
how do you find time to read and retain
at least a working knowledge of all the
author's books you read
oh I don't I'm very bad at that like
it's almost a joke within this household
here with Jennifer and myself where when
it comes to fiction like reading novels
or watching movies and stuff like that
if I only read a book once or what see
movie once a couple years later I will
have no idea what happened the plot of
movies and novels just disappears in my
brain very very quickly and there's a
similar thing that happens with
non-fiction books also I mean I retain
some knowledge of things by sort of
going over them multiple times you know
I look I've read looked back at the
transcripts of podcasts I did a year ago
and go huh that's really interesting
that we're talking about there when I
mean it's the podcasts are worse
actually to be honest because when I am
recording them I'm thinking you know
ferociously about like where to go next
in the conversation did we cover this
particular thing am i running out of
time is that I hit the record button and
all these things what does the sound
quality like and so it's sort of
remarkable how little I am able to
retain afterwards so looking over the
transcripts is useful given as I said
before that I don't like actually
listening to my own voice dan O'Neill
says I know that much of modern physics
is inaccessible to those of us without
the requisite mathematical knowledge but
do you ever find that you get too caught
up in the math not just in calculating
and problem solving but even in your
more creative theoretical mathematical
work to the point where you lose touch
with a wonder and strangeness of the
reality the math represents I'm not
exactly sure that I understand what
you're asking but I think if I get it my
answer is yes and no I mean I think I
think I appreciate where you're coming
from it's it's definitely true that when
you're tackling physics problems and
then you're motivated by some physics
question and you bring some mathematics
to bear on that physics question there
is an intrinsic beauty and seductiveness
in good math right and so sometimes
doing that math and
and understand the physics problem leads
you to ask another mathematical question
that is a little bit removed from the
physical motivation that you started
with and you can keep going in that
direction to the point where you're
basically just doing math and that's not
necessarily bad doing math is a good
thing but it's different from doing
science from doing physics my preference
is absolutely physics so if anything I'm
the opposite like if anything I've
written maybe a couple of papers on
topology and things like that which were
more math than physics but I tend to err
on the other side that I get impatient
with really complicated math because my
preference is to absolutely find the
nugget of simple beautiful physics
underneath all of it and the math tends
to get in the way for me more often than
I get lost in the beauty of it
Gregor Ani Locke says as far as I can
tell the entropy definition has to do
with the distinction of microscopic and
macroscopic States isn't it subjective
to the observer what counts as
macroscopic why doesn't it cause similar
controversy as using the observer and
other laws of physics like quantum
mechanics well it's a little bit
different entropy I mean you're right
there is an assassin that comes in when
you define entropy but it turns out if
you sort of go beyond that and look into
what actually goes on it's not that bad
okay it's like there's a subjective
element taste some people like some food
and some people like other food yet
again it's not like all hell's broken
loose you can go to a restaurant and
everyone recognizes that some
restaurants are good and some
restaurants are less good okay there is
still an enormous amount of overlap and
consensus when it comes to what tastes
good even though it is fundamentally
subjective that is not exactly a perfect
analogy but a pretty good analogy for
entropy yes it's subjective but when you
look at something when you look at a cup
of coffee with cream mixing into it you
see where the cream is and you see where
the coffee is you don't see the
positions and the velocities of all the
different molecules and that's true for
everybody we all see more or less the
same picture of cream mixing into coffee
so we use what we can see when we define
entropy we say the entropy is the
logarithm of the number of microscopic
states that look the same to us
macroscopically but that's okay that's
good enough to get a quantity which we
can use in physics equations and agree
on from person to person
John Farr says if you ran the planet and
all its resources what would your top
three or more priorities be so when I
first read this question I instantly
said oh I don't have any such list of
priorities but I thought about it for
five seconds and I realized I kind of do
have a list of priorities you know
priority one would be climate change
that's pretty obvious by the way my list
of priorities is not very clever it's
not very innovative I'm not trying to be
contrary and I think that they're the
pretty obvious priorities climate change
would be one I would want to fix the
second one would be democracy I want to
make I would want to make sure if I ran
the planet that we had a functioning
democracy which maybe is incompatible
with me running the planet but maybe I
have a some sort of benevolent
dictatorship where I where I use my
powers to run the planet just to make
sure everyone is really being a well
functioned democracy and then I think I
originally thought that my third one
would be really clamping down on nuclear
proliferation to lower the risks of a
nuclear explosion because that would be
tremendously terrible but after a little
bit of contemplation I think that
poverty and disease elimination would be
what I would want to do so there and I
say poverty and disease they're two
different things obviously but they're
closely related if we could get people
in lesser well-off portions of the world
to have some money to have a basic
income whether it's the traditional
policy of universal basic income or just
my magical powers of as runner up the
planet but get people to have the
ability to buy things to lift themselves
out of poverty the world would be a much
better place and disease would go down
you could use some of that money to help
build infrastructure right to help build
hospitals and schools and stuff like
that that's what I would want to do
cleitus black says if general
intelligence does not require an organ
connection is it fair to say that a
system of a dog plus a human working
together and viewed as one collective
system is more generally intelligent in
many survival situations then either the
dog or human alone is I mean there's
probably a sense in which that's true
but my suspicion without having thought
about it very deeply is that it's not a
very profound sense I think that you
know when us when you talk about the
word intelligence ok which is what are
you doing you have to talk about the
intelligence of what right it wouldn't
make much sense to talk about the
intelligence of you know just our
cerebellum or you know just our pineal
gland or other parts of the brain the
thing that has an intelligence in some
way is the whole person and I don't
think it makes sense to say a human plus
a dog is a system that has intelligence
you can try to do it but you're
obviously doing violence to the concept
that you started with I think it just
makes more sense to talk about the
composite system the team of the human
and the dog the human has some
intelligence for some things the dog has
some intelligence for some things there
are certain tasks that they can do
better than either one of them
individually but I wouldn't ascribe to
them intelligence in the same way I
would to a person robert Murli says what
happens exactly when the universe splits
is there then two universes each with
all the space and mass of the original
since mass is equivalent to energy where
does all the new energy come from I'm
gonna have to like write some blog post
or something about this because this is
I'm not I'm not trying to give you a
hard time Robert but this is an
extraordinarily frequently asked
question the answer is there's two
different ideas of energy okay there's
the idea of energy that you have as seen
from the point of view of an observer
inside the universe and there's a energy
that you have as seen from God's eye
view looking at the wave function
describing all the universes at once
from within the universe the fact that
the universe branches and there's now
another universe is completely
irrelevant to you essentially the energy
you have before or after branching is
the same it's not exactly the same
because as I already mentioned
earlier there can be a slight deviation
when you measure a quantum system the
energy can change but still it's
basically the same but there's another
definition of energy which is the total
energy of all the universes at once that
energy is modified is modulated by the
amplitude by the thickness by the size
of the universe that is contributing to
the wave function overall and so even
though there are now two universes each
with an equal amount of energy where
there used to be just one each of those
universes only contributes a fraction to
the unit to the energy of the whole
shabang and the fraction adds up to one
so the energy of the whole shabang did
not change and again this is an example
where the math is crystal SuperDuper
clear there's zero no controversy within
the physics community about energy
conservation in many worlds we all know
what it is it's just really really hard
to explain in English because the words
just don't match Martin Ziggler Ziggler
says you've mentioned that you enjoy
playing poker do you actually try to
calculate in real time while playing
updates to the conditional probabilities
of winning so yes absolutely
now maybe what you mean is do I actually
use bayes's theorem to do that which
would be hard
okay bases theorem is the correct
formalization of how you update your
credence --is based on new information
coming in but actually multiplying
things out correctly and normalizing
correctly would be a mess but what you
absolutely do is to say well someone
hasn't done anything in the hand yet I
give an equal probability to them having
any two cards other than the two that I
have and they do something right they
make it backed or they call or they
check or they fold or whatever that
information changes quite dramatically
the credence that I have on them having
a certain kind of hand if someone in
early position who has been very very
tight that is to say not getting
involved in a lot of pots someone early
positions suddenly raises an otherwise
unraised pot my credence is very high
that they have a very very good hand a
high pair or ace
or something like that that's what every
poker player does and if you want more
details I did a whole podcast interview
with love Bri Liv Boeree who is a
professional poker player and we talked
about exactly this we go into detail
about that
Leonard Levy says you presume the
decision-making is not a quantum event
therefore does not split the universe
what about a decision which leads to an
action I feel an impulse to scratch the
tip of my nose I can decide to act on
that impulse or to inhibit it whichever
decision I make will lead to decoherence
as my index finger interacts with
different photons as it scratches my
nose than when it rests on the armrest
of a chair doesn't that split the
universe in the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics so
no it does not because the decision that
you made was entirely classical you made
the same decision in every branch of the
wave function of the universe the only
way for you to branch the wave function
of the universe is to measure a quantum
system that is in some kind of super
position and had that quantum system
become entangled with the world around
it so if you made your decision by
consulting a quantum random number
generator then there would be different
branches in which you did different
things but the thing that brought those
different branches into existence was
the quantum random number generator not
the decision that you made Gregory
kuzmic proposes a general relativity
paradox a meter stick is flying past me
and very close to the speed of light and
its own reference frame is still a meter
long but I see it Lorentz contracted to
within its own Schwarzschild radius what
in my frame keeps it from collapsing
into a black hole well it's probably the
answer is what you're gonna guess it is
maybe there's no rule in general
relativity that says that when something
is inside its own Schwarzschild radius
in somebody's frame it collapses into a
black hole because after all you're
within your short you'll read yes to in
the frame of high-energy particle moving
past you close to the speed of light and
you don't collapse into a black hole and
the reason is who cares
what someone else in some other frame
observes what matters to you is whether
you are in your short shield radius in
your own rest frame that is the
criterion that you use for whether or
not you collide
into a black hole otherwise relativity
just wouldn't be sensible who would have
different predictions for different
people that's exactly the opposite for
physical phenomena that's exactly the
opposite of what relativity is supposed
to be about Gareth Butler asks what is
an operator as used in equations
basically an operator is just something
that takes a function and turns into
another function so you have the
operator multiplied by two okay that's a
very simple operator you have some
function of X you multiply it by two you
get a new function of X many operators
are more complicated in that like the
derivative of a function is an operator
or you can take two derivatives or you
can take a derivative and multiply it by
two and add the results together all
sorts of different possible things this
is a very useful concept in quantum
mechanics because the function we're
dealing with is the wave function and
we're continually operating on it to
turn into some other function it's also
true that you don't need necessarily to
go all the way to a function if you just
have a vector you can operate on the
vector by rotating it by extending it in
some direction and so forth that's
really all it means of course it becomes
complicated when you think about
different kinds of operators unitary
operators hermitian operators that's
when you get into the math of linear
algebra and so on Clive Thompson says
given Earth's particular location in the
Milky Way we see particular patterns in
the Stars from our specific vantage
point Orion's belt Southern Cross
etcetera how good is our current mapping
of the Milky Way in all
three-dimensional glory so that's a
great question because it has recently
become much much better with work from
the Gaia satellite so it's very
difficult in astronomy to realize to
figure out the distances to stars and to
galaxies and so forth seeing where they
are an angle on the sky their position
on the sky is easy even measuring their
redshift is easy but measuring their
actual physical distance is very very
hard so four stars in the Milky Way what
you ideally want is a satellite around
the earth that can look at the stars
from slightly different positions as the
earth goes around the Sun or as the
satellite goes around this
and then see the tiny tiny motions in
the apparent positions of those stars
due to parallax - just looking at them
from different angles so there was a
satellite called Hipparchus that did
this a couple decades ago but not to
very high precision there's been a more
recent satellite called the Gaia
satellite that has done this to amazing
precision I don't know exactly the
details but we're talking about
literally billions of stars that we have
now figured out more or less their 3d
positions so the nearby galaxies
certainly we know quite well what what
the positions of all the stars look like
Brian Miller says if gravity is due to
the warping of space-time why do we talk
about gravitons as the force carrying
particles for gravity so this is just an
example of two very different languages
that mean the same thing okay gravitons
come into the picture when you talk
about quantum gravity but their ultimate
effect is exactly the same as the
classical description of a warped
space-time causing the gravitational
field it's exactly the same as
electromagnetism where we have electric
fields and magnetic fields but then if
you dig down into the quantum level it's
convenient to talk about photons but
we're still talking about exactly the
same thing a classical electromagnetic
field is just a bunch of photons piled
on top of each other and exactly the
same thing is true for gravity a warped
space-time is just a bunch of gravitons
piled on top of each other now when
you're talking about a black hole or the
expanding universe some very large-scale
very dramatic gravitational effect this
language of piling gravitons on top of
each other isn't very useful so nobody
uses it but it could be there if you
really wanted to bend over backwards for
some reason
Zachery stopa says some theorists such
as brian greene and others have
postulated that every possible reality
will be realized somewhere some when I
believe I heard you say that infinity
does not necessarily guarantee a
manifestation of every possible reality
to get more plain-spoken
even an infinite construct there's no
guarantee somewhere someone that I was
the MVP of the National Hockey League
last year or is there so let me clarify
a few things here it's absolutely true
that there's no reason to think that
just because there are an infinite
number of universes in whatever sense of
universe you mean either the many-worlds
of quantum mechanics or different pocket
universes in cosmology even if there's
an infinite number of them doesn't mean
everyone exists the one example I always
like to use is electrical charge is
conserved so there's no universe in
which neutrons turn into protons without
any other particles being emitted okay
but many weird things can happen in the
quantum mechanical universe you can put
a coffee cup on a table and it can
tunnel right through and fall to the
bottom that's very very very unlikely
but it's a tiny little part of the
wavefunction the universe so there is a
world in which it happens so I don't
know exactly whether or not you being
the MVP of the National Hockey League
would violate any important laws of
physics so I don't know whether it's a
possible thing that actually comes true
in the wave function of the universe but
let me emphasize the other things I
wanted to say which is that it's not you
who would be the MVP of the National
Hockey League
because you're not in that universe ok
different copies of your previous self
that are now in different universes are
different people so there's you can't
even say things like oh yes in a
different universe I am doing this in a
different universe there's no you you
live in this universe Brian Larson says
as I understand it the terms
superposition essentially means a linear
combination of states is this correct or
is there more to it what I'm what am I
missing that makes it inappropriate to
talk about a Northwest velocity as a
superposition of a west and north
velocity nope you're not missing
anything that is basically what it means
the important fact here is that quantum
states are vectors the wavefunction is a
vector in Hilbert space you can add them
together you can take linear
combinations and that's exactly what a
superposition is the reason why we use
different language to talk about super
positions in quantum theory than in
other contacts like the direction you're
walking in is because when you observe
quantum things you only see certain
outcomes you only see the electron
either spin up or spin down you don't
see it in a superposition of both so if
you just saw the wave function every
time you observed it everyone would know
the
the universe was described by a vector
and that's how we should talk about it
and you wouldn't emphasize this idea
that it's a superposition of certain
definite measurement outcomes but
because we only do see certain
measurement outcomes the way that we
think about the vector is its
relationship to the measurement outcomes
namely that it is a superposition of
different possible measurement outcomes
that's why we use that language so often
in quantum theory unders Hedlund says
I'm interested in the decay of
radioactive materials and why we say
it's impossible to know when in time and
particularly decays exactly what part of
quantum mechanics makes it impossible to
predict when it happens this is one of
those questions that depends on your
favorite approach to the foundations of
quantum mechanics because different
people are going to give you different
answers if you believe in an objective
collapse model like the grw models or
penn roses model which we've already
mentioned in this podcast then the laws
of physics have an intrinsically
unpredictable feature to them it just
says you know something's gonna happen
with a certain probability and you can't
say exactly when that's it . if you
believe in a hidden variables theory
then there is a definite position to all
the hidden variables but you don't know
what they are and so you have some
ignorant and that's why the best you can
do is to talk probabilistically about
what the measurement outcomes are going
to be if you believe in many worlds all
the outcomes are going to be possible
but once the universe branches into the
possible outcomes it can branch into
there will be many copies of you and
none of those copies of you will know
which branch they're on so there is once
again probability there I actually wrote
a little essay that I think appeared in
quanta magazine online that you can
search for about how different
approaches to the theory of probability
intersect with different approaches to
quantum mechanics if you want to look
that up
Aleksandra is on e says we often have to
make decisions based on information and
fields about which we know little for
example when we look at someone's health
or economic policy before voting for
them what is your approach to evaluating
information in fields where you have no
expertise and where there isn't a very
obvious expert consensus so this is a
great question actually I've been
thinking about it
very off handedly and casually I don't
have a full-blown theory of it but the
general question is you know the role of
expertise and external opinions in
regimes where there's not a consensus
among the experts and and where you
yourself are not an expert I don't have
any you know brilliant once-and-for-all
plan here but I have sort of the usual
advice that any sensible person would
say which is you know look at the
experts so there will be experts that
disagree about things so not just health
policy but the foundations of quantum
mechanics is another example where
experts absolutely disagree as a non
expert I think in in those cases it is
wise not to have two definite a belief
about anything right if the people who
are experts don't have a definite set of
beliefs considered as a collective then
why in the world should the rest of us
have definite beliefs but also you can
sometimes even if you're not an expert
yourself get a feeling for what experts
seem more trustworthy if you know what I
mean
you can just listen to how they explain
themselves right are they dogmatic do
they seem to be talking in certain ways
because there's other forces or
incentives that are nudging them in the
direction of doing that or are they
truly seeking the answers in open-minded
good-faith way do they give answers that
are convincing and compelling even to
those of us who are not experts etc so I
think that even if you're not an expert
yourself it's possible to develop an
ability to judge the trustworthiness of
different kinds of experts outside your
own knowledge base and that's a very
important helpful thing but again still
even then I would not become dogmatic
about anything where I was not an expert
myself if the complete set of experts
themselves disagreed Gerardo even says
I'm curious what is changing physically
in the system when it arrives in a
situation with less gravity if this can
only be explained by explaining how time
works well you've already given me an
answer so I mean I think that it's safe
to say that nothing changes physically
in a system when it arrives in a
situation with less gravity it's very
hard in general relativity to even the
fine what you mean by a situation with
less gravity remember general relativity
is a very local theory it explains what
happens at different points in space and
space-time and then it explains the
relationship between them if you
literally travel from one point in
space-time to another but what it
doesn't want you to do not you know it
doesn't absolutely prohibit it but
general relativity gently suggests that
you not simultaneously compare what is
happening at two distantly separated
locations in space-time because there's
no unique way to do that when you go
through the math you find that there's
no way to actually sort of figure out
both how fast a clock is ticking at one
location in space and also how fast a
clock is ticking at another location in
space simultaneously there is no notion
of simultaneity like that in general
relativity so if you just look locally
at what clocks do all clocks move at one
second per second no matter what they do
okay so locally there's no difference
between what happens to systems in
different amounts of gravity globally
there's a difference that is to say if
you have two clocks that start at the
same location in space-time and they
travel on different trajectories and
then they come back because they have
different speeds or they travel through
different gravitational fields they will
experience a totally different an amount
of time interval that is different
overall but it's not a local difference
it's that global difference just like
walking along a different path takes you
a different amount of distance if you go
a straight line versus a curved line
Neal Glue says general relativity is
based on a manifold and other stuff but
there are many kinds of manifolds
topological once differentiable twice
differentiable smooth analytic etc and
there are manifolds with and without
boundaries do physicists have a strong
feeling about what kind of manifold
describes the world we live in so this
might not make any any sense this
question do people who don't know a
little bit of math but indeed there are
you know the idea of a manifold is basic
to general relativity and there's
different different levels of manifold
if you want in the math literature so
what you need
for general relativity is a manifold
that is twice differentiable you can
take derivatives of the functions on the
manifold at least twice so you need to
be able to differentiate the metric at
least twice to be able to define the
curvature tensor for example you might
want more than that you it's very often
that people just for convenience assume
that their manifolds are as smooth as
they need to be is a very typical
physicist move okay
mathematicians are like tell me how
smooth your manifold is physicists are
like don't worry it's smooth enough I'm
not going to worry about that and
there's a good reason they don't worry
about that because probably the universe
is not a manifold okay general
relativity is a classical theory arguing
too much in depth and in detail about
the niceties of the mathematical
formalism of general relativity takes
you away from physics because we know
that ultimately the world is going to be
quantum gravity not classical general
relativity and in quantum gravity the
world is in a smooth manifold at all
it's a wavefunction so I think that the
physicists attitude of saying that
they're manifolds are as smooth as they
need to be is probably the right one
given that we don't understand
ultimately how gravity works in the real
world okay the final question is from
Lothian 53 in relativity we talked about
not being able to test whether or not we
are moving as long as the motion is
constant meaning that the speed of light
is the same measurements of magnetic or
electric fields are the same as cetera
now that we have dark energy is the
acceleration of the expansion of the
universe also the same strength and
symmetry regardless of the direction or
the speed we move so I think that the
answer is no here but we have to be a
little bit careful because when we do
cosmology we generally do talk about a
certain preferred reference frame namely
the rest frame of the matter and the
Cosmic Microwave Background photons in
the universe so the theory of relativity
says it doesn't matter what speed you're
moving at the laws of physics are all
the same etcetera but that is a
statement about the fundamental laws of
physics it's not a statement about the
particular situation in which you find
yourself if you walk into a wall there's
a big difference to you whether you walk
into it quickly or slowly right that's
because the wall is effectively define
a preferred rest frame with respect to
which you can compare how fast you're
moving
likewise in cosmology we have a universe
that is scattered with galaxies and dark
matter and photons and together they
provide a rest frame with respect to
which we can talk about things like the
expansion rate of the universe so it
doesn't really quite make mathematical
sense to say well is the universe
expanding at a different rate in a
different rest frame you know regardless
of the direction in which we move the
expansion of the universe is a global
phenomenon that we use to describe the
universe as a whole and that universe
has a rest frame that suggests how we
should make that description so there's
really no danger of people getting
different answers to the question how
fast is the universe expanding and so
forth okay that's the end of the
questions as they are currently asked I
know that you know sometimes there's a
time lapse I'm not going to get a chance
to quite edit to this and and post it
tonight so it'll probably appear
tomorrow and maybe people will ask more
questions and I will not have answered
I'm sorry about that but there's always
next month tune in next month for more
ask me anything questions I will once
again be releasing to this this to the
public a week after we release it here
to patreon supporters and remember that
I've also started a new video series the
biggest ideas in the universe you can
find on youtube on my youtube channel or
on my web page and thanks everyone for
their patreon support thanks for
sticking with the mindscape podcast I
hope that it provides a little bit of
distraction from the mess all around us
because the universe keeps going is
important for us to keep thinking about
it take care see you next month
[Music]
you
[Music]